you or someone you care about
may have been diagnosed with bladder
cancer
this video will help you understand how
to manage it
the most common type of bladder cancer
called urothelial carcinoma
or transitional cell carcinoma is a
disease where cancer cells form
in the tissue lining the inside of your
bladder
for some people with bladder cancer
treatment may remove or destroy the
cancer
afterward you will receive a follow-up
care plan from your health care team
bladder cancer has a high risk of coming
back
so it's important to go to all of your
follow-up appointments
your doctor will want to make sure the
cancer has not returned
and check for health problems resulting
from treatment
if your bladder wasn't removed it's
important to get
regular cystoscopy exams to check for
cancer
during a cystoscopy a thin viewing
instrument
will be inserted into your bladder to
look for signs of cancer
talk to your oncologist about any
medications you are taking
and continue to take them as prescribed
by your doctor
unless instructed otherwise
take note of any side effects and tell
your doctor
if you had bladder surgery or other
treatments follow
any instructions you were given
you may also need to make some of the
following healthy lifestyle changes
if you smoke it's important to quit
smoking
this lowers the risk for bladder cancer
returning or getting other types of
cancer
limit how much alcohol you drink it may
reduce your risk of cancer returning
eat a healthy diet with more fruits
vegetables and whole grains
this will help you stay strong and feel
better
become physically active activities like
walking
riding a bicycle or swimming can help
you feel better and less tired
talk to your doctor before starting an
exercise routine
knowing you have cancer can be
overwhelming
you may have worries about things like
your condition and how it affects your
family
treatments and hospital stays medical
bills
and your job fortunately there are ways
to cope with this
remember that your doctor and health
care team are there to answer
any questions you have
the following sources of support can
help you cope with your concerns
social workers faith leaders
counselors and support
groups talk to your doctor if you have
any questions about your treatment plan
medications or lifestyle changes to help
you manage bladder cancer